[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 nous sommes le mardi 1er février
voici les titres elle est la première
dans les yvelines carrières sous poissy
a reçu la semaine dernière le label cité
de la jeunesse décerné par l'état il
entend valoriser et donner davantage de
moyens aux structures locales innovantes
sur l'accompagnement des jeunes des
quartiers prioritaires qu'on en parle
avec rappel sodini préfet délégué pour
l'égalité des chances
chaque année 2500 cas de cancers
infantiles sont diagnostiqués en france
dans les yvelines une association
notamment récolte des fonds pour la
recherche contre la maladie les gbagbo à
man on a été créée par anne herbert
lorraine suite au décès de sa fille il
ya 17 ans
et puis ce ne sera ni marseille ni même
nantes ou monaco le football-club de
versailles affrontera bergerac en quarts
de finale de la coupe de france tout
comme les yvelinois les périgourdins
évolue en national de la 4e division
française réaction après ce tirage au
sort
mais avant de développer ses titres l'
enquête pour menace à l'encontre du
professeur de philosophie didier lemaire
classer sans suite cette décision du
parquet de versailles et début 2000 21
celui qui enseigne à trappes avait
dénoncé au travers d'une lettre ouverte
dans l'aube l'emprise islamistes sur la
ville parlant d'une commune totalement
perdu l affaire avait été grandement
médiatisée et ce quelques semaines après
l'assassinât de samuel paty et didier
lemaire qui n'exerce plus à trappes à
bénéficier d'une protection rapprochée
il se dit soulagé de cette décision du
parquet
c'était une demande de plusieurs
syndicats d'enseignants équiper les
structures scolaires de capteur de co2
la commune de magny les hameaux a fait
le choix d'en installer dans ses sites
municipaux comme les cantines et des
lieux fréquentés par les enfants une
vingtaine de boîtier a été ainsi
installé mélanie poker la lumière est
verte tout va bien la valeur limite de 8
100 ppm n'a pas été atteinte ce capteur
a été installé mi janvier dans cette
cantine de l'école saint-exupéry magny
les hameaux a fait le choix des capteurs
de co2 dans des lieux communaux ça nous
permet
d'accompagner on va dire la la sécurité
sanitaire dans dans les lieux en
priorité ou les enfants ne porte pas de
masque dans notre
système éducatif et de garde et garde
des enfants on s'aperçoit qu'il ya un
certain nombre d'endroits qui sont
propices au développement
du code vide pas que commandé début
décembre les vins capteur se trouvent
principalement dans les réfectoires et
salle d'activités il mesure la charge en
co2 émettent un signal sonore et un
signal lumineux en cas de forte
concentration j'ai vu nous directement
en observant un petit peu ce qui nous
est dit au niveau scientifique
et puis on voyait aussi que dans le
domaine scolaire il y un certain nombre
de demandes des personnels vis-à-vis de
leur employeur vis-à-vis de l'éducation
nationale on voyait qu'il n'y avait pas
vraiment de retour de la part
l'éducation nationale voilà nous en tant
que commune en nos responsabilités coût
environ une centaine d'euros par
capteurs l'achat est pour le moment 100
% financés par le budget communal une
demande de financement a été déposée
auprès de l'état pour la première fois
depuis mi décembre le nombre de
contaminations que 8,19 à baisser dans
les yvelines en une semaine le taux
d'incidence a reculé de 1000 cas pour
100000 habitants et face à cette
évolution sanitaire le préfet
jean-jacques brot a pris un nouvel
arrêté qui entre en vigueur ce mercredi
2 février terminez l'obligation du port
du masque en extérieur depuis le 16
janvier la mesure était déjà en place
dans une grande partie du territoire
mais le port du masque reste est
obligatoire dans certaines circonstances
l'obligation demeure active en revanche
pour les lieux en intérieur ceux
recevant du public dans les transports
et dans les stades
[Musique]
après les sites et éducative le
ministère la cohésion des territoires
lancé en mai dernier les cités de la
jeunesse un label pour valoriser donner
davantage de moyens humains et
financiers à des structures locales on
en parle avec raphaël sodini bonsoir
vous êtes le préfet délégué pour
l'égalité des chances dans les yvelines
une commune yvelinoise vient de recevoir
justement ce label et c'est une première
dans le département il s'agit et de
carrières sous poissy grâce à sa maison
de la jeunesse et de la réussite
découverte de ce lieu avec mélanie poker
comme chaque jour sada animateurs et
éducateurs de la maison de la jeunesse
et de la réussite de carrières sous
poissy répondre aux interrogations du
public les bénéficiaires de ce lieu ce
sont les jeunes aident à l'information
parcours vers l'autonomie trois
animateurs et une coordinatrice à nîmes
de l'information et de l'ecoute nous on
aime beaucoup cambiasso confiance sont
larges y aussi perso surtout sur la deux
persos qui ont des problèmes dans leur
famille quant à son conflit avec leurs
parents comment tous les aider on nous
oriente les acomptes un des 16-25 dans
tout ce qui est cv lettre de motivation
à copains mais aussi deux fois d'aller
demander de logements les accompagne un
peu on les oriente surtout aussi le
domaine de la caf nous en tant que tout
lieu d'information mais aussi lieux de
détente avec des activités organisées
inauguré en septembre 2021 cette maison
a pris place dans les anciens locaux de
la bibliothèque municipale
plus de 500 jeunes ont déjà été
accompagné le 27 janvier la structure a
été labellisé cité de la jeunesse par la
ministre de la ville c'est une démarche
qui vient on reconnaît tout un
engagement des professionnels du secteur
et puis il ya un accompagnement
financier qui n'est pas négligeable pour
une collectivité territoriale
ces cent mille euros par an pendant deux
ans et donc nous allons des employés à
bon escient évidemment mais en les
flèches en particulier sur les
problématiques d'accès à l'emploi et
l'insertion le site accueille aussi la
mission locale et le bureau information
jeunesse à carrières sous poissy 20% des
moins de 25 ans sont actuellement sans
emploi les moins de 30 ans représentent
42 % de la population
cette maison de la jeunesse et la
réussite on a l'impression a fait le
fooding c'est une sorte de guichet
unique le jeune peut venir s'y informer
également y travailler c'est il ya plein
de services oui c'est exactement l'idée
c'est de regrouper dans un lieu unique
l'ensemble des services et des
informations dont un jeune peut avoir
besoin à la fois pour résoudre ses
difficultés personnelles
ces difficultés administratives et puis
aussi ses démarches d'insertion et puis
c'est aussi un lieu où il y aura des
moments conviviaux qui vont être
organisées par la mairie où les jeunes
pourront se retrouver ou ce qui peut
être ont le plus de mal à franchir les
portes d'institutions un peu intimidante
comme pôle emploi ou une caf 1 pourront
aller dans cette maison de la réussite
trouver des réponses à leurs questions
et des premiers pas vers une démarche
d'insertion alors alors c'est possible
mais les chiffres sont assez similaires
dans les autres villes en quartiers
prioritaires le taux de chômage atteint
10 9 % chez les moins de 25 ans en quoi
est-ce important intéressant aussi de
regrouper en un même lieu centralisé
finalement tous ces services vous le
soulignez le taux de chômage des jeunes
c'est à peu près 20% en moyenne mais
dans les quartiers prioritaires en
politique de la ville ça peut atteindre
30 % et on a beaucoup de jeunes dans nos
quartiers qui ne font même pas la
démarche d'aller s'inscrire au chômage
qui reste sans emploi sans formation
finalement à attendre et à végéter en se
sentant exclus de nos dispositifs l'idée
d'avoir un lieu comme ça on a à la fois
des activités conviviales dans lequel
les jeunes se sentent bien et puis des
activités d'insertion professionnelle
c'est justement l'idée de raccrocher ces
jeunes à nos dispositifs c'est très
important que ce soit à proximité de
quartiers en politique de la ville et à
carrières sous poissy il ya deux
quartiers en politique de la ville et
c'est très important que ce lieu trouve
son public et permettent à son public de
saint céré on a déjà parlé avec vous
aura fait le feu dîner sur ce plateau
des sites éducatifs demain jeudi la
ministre délégué à la ville mahdia et
valence et attrape la première cité de
l'emploi à trappes ça fait beaucoup de
sites et quelle est la différence entre
cité éducative cité de la jeunesse cité
de l'emploi trois dispositifs en a que
trois cas vous les avez tous cités cité
éducative cité de l'emploi cité de la
jeunesse cité éducative c'est un
dispositif en partenariat avec
l'éducation nationale qui vise à créer
dans les quartiers en politique de la
ville autour de l'école un écosystème
pour favoriser l'apprentissage des
enfants on a maintenant neuf cité
éducative sur le département des
yvelines parce que quatre nouvelles ont
été labellisés ce week end par le
premier ministre donc on en a quatre
nouvelles à plaisir limay mantes la
ville et sartrouville on a trois sites
et de l'emploi donc la ministre ira
inaugurer celle de saint quentin en
yvelines demain attrape la cité de
l'emploi c'est pas que pour les jeunes
pour l'ensemble des personnes de 16 à 60
ans regrouper l'ensemble des services de
l'emploi et créer un écosystème avec le
monde de l'entreprise et puis enfin la
cité de la jeunesse là y'en a que quinze
au plan national et une seule sur le
département des yvelines c'est celle de
carrières sous poissy et là comme je les
dis c'est une sorte de guichet unique
vous l'avez très bien dit pour les
jeunes pour que les jeunes trouvent
l'ensemble des réponses à leurs
questions les sur ces sites et de la
jeunesse sur quels critères sont
sélectionnés justement les villes pour
avoir ce label alors en fait c'était une
volonté du maire
le gouvernement nous propose une série
de la belle une série de dispositifs
alors il ya des critères en fonction de
la taille de la population et puis ici
très clairement c'est le maire de le
maire de carrières sous poissy eddie aït
qui avait cette idée de créer un lieu
unique pour les jeunes il y avait ce
label du gouvernement et donc on a fait
comme c'est notre travail converger les
deux verres vers cette belle réussite
donc à la clé on a compris des moyens
humains et financiers
il semble il voit là des moyens humains
et financiers cent mille euros par an
délégués par l'état et puis au delà de
ça une volonté d'inscrire cette cité de
la jeunesse dans les nouveaux
dispositifs qui vont être mis en place
au 1er mars sur le contrat d'engagement
jeunes qui va permettre à tous les
jeunes de moins de 25 ans qui sortent
des études d'avoir pendant un an un
soutien financier de l'état pour
s'insérer donc ça aussi cette cité de la
jeunesse devrait être un lieu où on va
signer des contrats d'engagement jeunes
et on permet aux jeunes de s'insérer
dans l'emploi et de réussir leur entrée
dans la vie active je vous le disais à
la base y'a pas de sélection en tant que
tel c'est la ville qui fait d'abord la
démarche vous êtes là dans un rôle
d'accompagnement pour monter le dossier
la candidature exactement la ville fait
la démarche en fait la ville a candidaté
très officiellement auprès de madame la
ministre lorsque la ministre était venu
en avril dernier pour dans un dialogue
avec les maires et puis on l'a
accompagné on a construit avec son
cabinet le cabinet de la ministre la
ville la déléguée du préfet qui a fait
l'intermédiaire on a on a construit un
marin projet qui a été retenu donc on
est on est d'abord très heureux parce
que c'est l'aboutissement d'un travail
mais maintenant s'il va falloir nourrir
cette cité de la jeunesse pour en faire
un lieu prisé de la jeunesse de
carrières sous poissy mais qu'est-ce qui
a fait la différence c'est que c'est un
lieu un peu unique
le alors il ya un mois d un des locaux
qui s'y prêtait très bien cette ancienne
bibliothèque et dans une maison très
bien situé à carrières sous poissy il y
avait une volonté municipale je crois de
regrouper de regrouper les
les différentes administrations et les
différents services et il y avait oui je
crois une volonté politique du
gouvernement de faire en sorte qu'on ait
à carrières sous poissy un dispositif
innovant pour les jeunes on peut être à
la fois site éducatif cité de la
jeunesse cité de l'emploi on essaye ces
opérations métier afin de répartir un
petit peu les choses
l'important c'est que tous ces
dispositifs en politique de la ville
produisent un service de qualité qui
permettent l'insertion de nos jeunes et
donc j'essaye évidemment de répartir un
peu tout ça de manière de manière aussi
intelligente que possible et aussi
cohérente que possible d'ailleurs
question car fois ci c'est la première
c'était la jeunesse qu'il y en aura
d'autres alors sur le département des
yvelines je ne pense pas en tout cas pas
dans l'immédiat on va voir il y en a que
15 en france donc en avoir une dans les
yvelines c'est déjà bien et puis on
verra après c'est à cette cité de la
jeunesse de grossir et de démontrer que
ce dispositif un peu innovant ben fait
ses preuves et touchons public alors
peut-être d'autres sites et de la
jeunesse verront le jour merci rafale
soit digne d'être venu en parlant
plateau merci beaucoup et je rappelle
préfet délégué pour l'égalité des
chances dans les yvelines
[Musique]
suite au décès de sa fille emportée par
un cancer année à herbert lorraine a
décidé de créer une association pour
récolter des fonds au profit de la
recherche sur les cancers pédiatriques
les baggies à manon a permis de récolter
six cent mille euros en 17 ans zoom avec
mathilde franco et bixente malien
santisteva la nouvelle famille on l'a
trouvé dans les bagages ce que à nous a
apporté ça a dépassé tout çà c'est même
plus palpable c'est voilà c'est le coeur
c'est pour toi une tatie super génial
margot diagnostiqué d'un cancer doit
être soigné à paris au centre gustave
roussy toute la famille basé à cayenne
en guyane des ménages en france
désorienté alexandre a trouvé un
véritable soutien auprès de anne
fondatrice de l'association les bagouzes
amman ont créé il y a dix sept ans suite
au décès de sa fille atteinte d'un
cancer avant qu'on parte pour l'airé san
sur gustave roussy on m'a donné le
contact de l'association en disant
vraiment
elle peut
anne peut t'aider dans
te dire ce qu'il convient de faire dans
les orientations
elle est passée par là donc elle pourra
vraiment te conseiller sur ou allez quoi
faire etc sachant très bien qu'à paris
pas de famille pas d'amis pas de soutien
est donc tout contact tour les est bon à
prendre parce qu'on sait pas de quoi
demain sera fait en 2005 anne décide de
commencer à récolter de l'argent pour
financer la recherche contre les cancers
de l'enfant elle va alors les bacs
qu'elle fabriqué avec sa fille à
l'hôpital et fonds de son association
les bagouzes à manon aujourd'hui
l'association compte une vingtaine de
bénévoles et a récolté près de 600000
euros quand j'ai créé l'association est
à 17 ans je disais toujours c'est un
moyen de faire vivre ma non c'est elle
qui m'a insufflé toute cette force et
toute cette envie de soutenir la
recherche bat pour faire qu'on puisse
arriver aux résultats que l'on a
aujourd'hui avec margot qui est en
rémission parce que le cancer qu'elle à
se guérir très bien à l'occasion de la
journée internationale des cancers de
l'enfant l'association organise une
soirée le samedi 5 février dans la salle
l'ariana vélizy-villacoublay
100% des fonds collectés seront reversés
au profit de la recherche sur les
cancers de l'enfant
et puis le sport après l'euphorie de la
qualification retour au calme de la
préparation le football-club de
versailles va tenter de poursuivre
l'aventuré en coupe de france les
yvelines ont hérité de bergerac au
tirage au sort des quarts de finale
l'équipe évolue comme les versailles en
nationale 2 c'est la 4e division
française tombeurs des professionnels de
toulouse au tour précédent les
versaillais n'en reste pas moins
concentré wilfried richie et michael et
demi d'euros
il rêvait tous d'un autre tirage mais
finalement le sort en a décidé autrement
le football-club de versailles
rencontrera à l'extérieur en quarts de
finale de la coupe de france l'autre
petit poucet de la compétition bergerac
deux clubs de nationale 2 chacun leader
de sa poule en championnat et chacun
déterminés à accéder au dernier carré au
delà de jouer bergerac on est surtout
triste de départ où souvent pour notre
public ça reste un match de coupe quand
même mais c'est surtout une place qui
joue en cours la demi finale et on va te
donner de façon on se dit que tout est
possible pour aller en demi finale
réunis lundi soir pour assister à
l'annoncé des prochaines affiches les
joueurs devront donc attendre encore un
peu pour espérer affronter l'un des
clubs de ligue 1 encore en compétition
marseille nantes ou encore monaco en
attendant le déplacement à bergerac et
vainqueur de metz et saint-etienne au
tour précédent est loin d'être gagné
d'avancé ça nous laisse une chance de
passer en demi finales même si c'est une
équipe très sérieuse contre laquelle on
va jouer chez eux sur leur terrain ça
est un peu compliqué mais on va se
donner les moyens de passer
la rencontre se jouera le 9 février à
18h30 mais quel que soit le résultat il
y aura bien un club de nationale 2 en
demi finale de coupe de france cette
année
et ça c'est peut-être la bonne nouvelle
à retenir voilà c'est la fin de ce
journal merci de votre fidélité dans un
instant nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture
présentée par ces les gars de 100 go qui
parlera notamment du tremplin des voix
qui s'annonce à magny les hameaux belle
soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]